hey guys i'm just your average meme
connoisseur and game of thrones season 8
hater sliding in here to give my two
cents on juan division
this show from what it seemed amongst
fans started out to be somewhat
conflicting and confusing
but it turned out to be a pretty fun
ride with a lot of variety
to me that's what the mcu needed in its
current state because a couple of their
recent movies like captain marvel
didn't do enough to spice up the genre
given that that movie was just a generic
origin movie
but one division oh boy this show takes
the five stages of grief to a whole new
ballpark
the overall concept for the show and its
execution is stunning to watch unfolds
i don't know how the hell kevin feige
and the people at marvel came up with
this show
like oh yeah let's just have wanda
create an entire fantasy reality
with a sitcom theme that embodies
everything wanda wants
most because she's in mental anguish
from the death of vision
i want whatever that writing room is
having please
also the amount of detail that goes into
all the different period styles is
stunning
the acting and delivery changes the set
pieces change
the way its film changes new themes new
intros
and more all contribute to make that
viewing experience very engaging
one of my favorite examples is in the
first episode
in order to create a more eerie tone the
filmmakers opted for close-ups and slow
pushes
on the characters which is unnatural for
sitcoms
and in the behind the scenes they said
they were referencing a twilight zone
and that's just one moment from many
scenes that are doused with so much
nuance and care
that and i feel like there's no dull
moments during any of the sitcoms scenes
since wanda and vision are superheroes
they add a very original dynamic that
heightens the humor
and allows for some crazy scenarios to
unfold the whole concept
of zooming through a pregnancy in one
day in her kids speedrunning life is
absolute gold on a writing standpoint
i just gobbled up all the zany subvision
wanda had to go through
and i would have been completely down if
that's what all the show was
another highlight to me is the complete
aura of mystery that everything is
shrouded in
for the first three episodes i actually
felt like one of those youtubers that
creates theories upon
every sort of evidence that they were
given the mystery aspect allowed for so
much input of brain power from the
viewer
to try and figure everything out then
when they actually reveal something
it's like a massive dopamine hit
watching that fourth episode and
witnessing the events from the
perspective of monica rambo
you were able to piece together that
puzzle before the characters did
and you feel like this you know i'm
something of a scientist myself
to me this felt very rewarding and once
the mystery drops off a bit
the creators shake things up with the
surprise return of quicksilver
and speaking of quicksilver this is one
of the things that kind of bothered me
i was one of those people who had their
mind blown when evan peters came back as
quicksilver
oh my god okay it's happening everybody
stay calm
only to be let down by the ending reveal
that he's just some random guy
this is twice now that marvel has
dangled the multiverse in our faces
and faked us out for the sake of a joke
boner
it was okay the first time and far from
home when mysterio was lying about there
being a multiverse
and that on its own was the big twist
but for one division
they are practically breaking the fourth
wall by casting evan peters as the
resurrected quicksilver
this does make the whole dynamic crazier
and funnier
but you're inevitably setting up people
for some amount of disappointments
especially since the fans know that the
multiverse is eventually coming
given that the doctor strength sequel
has the multiverse of madness in its
title
another aspect i have some mixed
feelings about was the reveal that
agatha was the villain
all along this felt jarring to me
because it came across that wanda was
the primary villain
and then the blame just got shifted to
someone else at the end
for the whole show it was very apparent
that wanda was in the wrong given that
she was enslaving a whole town of people
who are being mentally tortured and then
at the end
wanna just like oh yeah agatha showed me
i was being a dick so you guys can just
go now
i don't know why agatha would help her
come to the realization
when she was the one trying to sabotage
things to begin with
looking more at agatha she seemed pretty
cool and had some depth
but it felt jarring to drastically throw
the story in a different direction
towards the end of the show
i also rewatched the show while making
butt is full of memes
and i didn't see any clues pointing
towards agatha being the villain besides
her calling out monica rambo
if they left some more clues pointing
towards agatha being the villain then
maybe it wouldn't feel as jarring
it is hard to complain about it though
because i really enjoyed the second to
last episode
i think it was very clever to utilize
magic as a means to access someone's
memories
and thus build their character besides
using a generic flashback
we learned more about wanda's character
while also moving the story forward
which to me is overall great
storytelling then the final battle does
turn
towards the more special effect type of
battle but the way in which wanda and
vision outsmarted their enemies was very
clever also that shiba theseus scene has
already become a big meme
overall i feel like the last third of
the show fell apart a bit
it became messier with the drastic
change in direction
and there were some plot elements that
were not elaborated enough on
like monica rambo had a big scene where
she got her powers
and then it mostly gets dropped and
isn't explored properly
her character literally gets sidelined
by a quicksilver and she disappears for
a whole episode
that and when she breaks out and beats
quicksilver she doesn't even use her
powers to do so
when she does end up using her powers
she just awkwardly shows up at the end
to save wanda's fake
kids which in of itself is kind of
stupid because she knows they aren't
real and she is for some reason willing
to die for them
at that point in the story she didn't
know much about her powers
so it's weird that she made the decision
to risk her life for some pixels
besides the weaker last start of the
show i still think it was pretty great
i'd basically give it a 4 out of 5.
but yeah i hope you guys enjoyed the
video and let me know what you thought
about the show in the comments
you